you
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday
my name is Gopala show product manager
in Google cloud today I'll be talking
about getting started with Redis on
Google Google cloud platform you can ask
questions anytime on the platform and
you we have Googlers on standby to
answer them let's get started when you
look at what's happening today with
businesses most of the businesses are
moving to public cloud platforms most of
you attending this webinar probably are
using Google cloud today or some other
public cloud platform or are interested
in moving to a public cloud platform
when we look at the various reasons why
customers want to move to a public cloud
platform there are various reasons one
is to reduce infrastructure cost
secondly they move to the public cloud
to gain more insights from data to use a
services in public cloud and analyze the
data and get more insights from it and
thirdly they want to properly build
applications so that they can deliver
services to their customers so
regardless of the reasons that you want
to move to the public cloud with Google
cloud platform we provide a number of
services that allows you to basically
build applications for your various
needs so if you look at the different
types of services that we provide in
Google cloud platform you have the
compute services so for example we have
the Google compute engine where you can
provide infrastructure as a service you
have the container engine so if you want
to deploy applications and kubernetes we
have a managed kubernetes service for
that or if you want to do like
serverless applications so there's App
Engine and cloud functions and then if
you want big data services like cloud
dataflow for stream processing or a
cloud data prop for managed to do there
are a number of services that allows you
to provide big data solutions so there
are more than there are more like if you
look at the security and identity
management services like cloud I am so
the bottom line is regard
of the kind of applications and services
that you want to provide in Google cloud
platform we provide a large number of
services to help you do that but
underlying all these applications and
services that you want to provide one of
the key services that you need is a
database and storage service so
depending on the application that you
build you want may want to have a
relational database or you may want to
have a no sequel database or you may
want to have something like data
warehouse so when you look at the
managed database and storage services
that Google Cloud provides we provide a
wide variety of these services so for
example if you want a relational
database we provide cloud spanner
so cloud spanner as you know is a
globally distributed transactional eager
consistent database or if you want to
have a document store you have cloud
datastore
or if you want to have a managed data
warehouse you have the query so as you
can see there's a wide variety of
services that you can choose from and
these are all managed services so that
you don't have to worry about managing
the databases yourself so one of the key
things that Google has focused on is
like for example if you look at cloud
spanner
you know cloud spanner was is one of the
you know really large-scale database
that Google uses internally to provide
their services so in this particular
case we provide those services in Google
cloud platform so that you can leverage
the power of cloud spanner and build
your app a distributed applications on
top of that so apart from providing the
the services that I just described one
of the other key focus that we have is
to make Google cloud platform and open
platform so what do I mean by that so
most of the customers today prefer to
build applications on open source
products one of the key reasons you want
to do that is because you want to be
able to port your applications anywhere
you want so for example if you're
building an application using Postgres
for example you want to be able to
either do that on Prem or if you move it
to another cloud provider you
want to be able to use Postgres in any
of the cloud providers so in Google we
are very much focused on providing open
source services so for example if you
look at the popular open source
databases that are currently available
and if you look at the DB engines
ranking for example you know my sequel
Postgres sequel elasticsearch Redis
etcetera very popular databases that
customers are using today to build
applications now if you want to use
those databases in Google cloud platform
those databases are available as
services that Google provides or there
are partner services that you can use to
leverage those databases for example if
you're using Postgres cloud sequel posts
for Postgres provides you a managed post
quest service and with managed service
as one of the key benefits that you get
of course is that you don't have to
manage a service you just have to focus
on building the application same thing
with my sequel so if you have my sequel
you can use cloud sequel for my sequel
if you're using each base for example we
have HBase compatible API is built on
top of cloud BigTable so open source is
a big focus for us now talking about
opens those databases Redis which is a
topic of today's conversation is one of
the most popular open-source databases
available today
now why is read as such a popular
database so from my perspective the way
I look at Brett is is that where this is
a very versatile in memory database so
when I talk about versatility of greta's
rare disk actually can be used to solve
a number of different use cases for
example brett has a lot of customers in
for example in Google Cloud today use
Redis for simple caching so when I talk
about caching it could be a simple as
caching some database queries or it
could be caching some API results the
other use cases for Redis typically are
session management where you just want
to you know as your session token' so
when customers will start off with Redis
for example they typically use it as a
simple cache but the versatility of
Redis comes from the fact that it is
actually a data structure server what I
mean by that is Redis provides a number
of powerful data structures
allows you to solve much bigger use
cases than simple caching
a very good example is Gaming
leaderboards so with sorted sets and
Redis it is very easy to build
leaderboards for gaming applications
similarly for stream processing or if
you are building IOT services Reuters
provides a number of great data
structures in order to do that so if you
look at how for an example of how Redis
gets used one of the example that we
commonly see is stream processing so in
Google cloud we see customers using
stream processing for solving quite a
number of different use cases this is a
very you know typical example that we
see where customers use cloud pub/sub
for basically ingesting events but that
they want to process so a very good
example is that if you want process like
corneal credit card transactions and you
want to be able to make decisions on
that you can use cloud pub/sub
which essentially is you know basically
an event streaming engine that allows
you to ingest events pretty quickly and
then you can use cloud dataflow in in
order to process these events very very
quickly one of the key use cases for
Redis that we see in this particular
architecture is that customers use Redis
to basically store states that they want
to really you know look up really
quickly or if they want to store some
aggregate data that they really want to
retrieve for further processing so this
is a very good example of how Redis gets
used for stream processing use case so
one of the key things that customers
have been asking from Google cloud
platform is that they want to be able to
have a manager at a service so to now
customers have been deploying their own
gratis instance and they've been
managing it themselves what I'm happy to
say is that we now have cloud memory
store cloud memory storage is currently
in beta is a fully managed in-memory
data store service for Redis so what I
want to do for the rest of the
presentation is to walk you through
clogged memory store and walk you
through the capabilities that we provide
like I mentioned the service is
currently
in beta so let's take a look at what
plot memory store provides so one of the
key principles that be followed for
cloud memory store is to make sure that
the service is fast scalable highly
available and secure and more
importantly we want to make sure that
you are focused on building applications
and we can take care of just managing
Redis for you and that's essentially
what we are doing with cloud memory
store so with memory store it's a fully
managed Redis service one of the key
things that we provide is high a high
availability so typically when you look
at cashing services you normally don't
see SFA's associated with it with cloud
memory store we provide three nines of
SLA for one of the tiers and finally we
are the memory store is obviously built
on Google's scalable infrastructure we
provide a high level of security based
on both the networking infrastructure
and also using role based access control
so I'll talk more about these features
in detail as we move forward but what I
just want to quickly point out that with
cloud memory store available in beta
it's going to be very easy to use Redis
to app with your application because now
you don't have to manage your own Redis
when in in Google cloud platform so
let's take a look at some of the
features and that are available with
called memory store today the first
thing I want to touch upon is how we
expose a service so cloud memory store
provides two tiers of service a basic
tier and a standard tier so what is a
basic tier so basic tier basically is a
single Redis instance where we see
customers use basic tier is when
customers want to use Redis as a simple
cache in this particular case
application can tolerate the reticence
ins losing the data and they simply want
to have a cache that is actually cheaper
and cost
the key thing about the basic tier is
that we do the instance monitoring so
what that means is that if something
happens to the instance we have health
monitoring in place that will basically
take care of restarting the instance and
recovering the instance from failure
when you recover the instance from
failure obviously the IP address is
maintained so that the applications
can't simply reconnect without any
changes on the application site one of
the key things about the basic gear that
I want to point out is that we don't
provide an SLA for the basic tier so the
standard tier is essentially what you
want to use if you rely on Redis as one
of as a as a key component in your
application and you want high
availability for Redis so what do we do
with the the in the standard tier we
provide a replicated instance of Redis
we provide one secondary replicas which
is deployed across zones so what that
means is that if there is a zonal
failure then you are applications are
unaffected because we automatically fade
over the reticences over to the the
other zone the other thing that we
provide is seamless scale-up of capacity
this is also available in basic tier but
the key difference here is that insanity
are when we do the scaling up of scaling
off the instance up and down we provide
high availability for the instance and
I'll talk more about it when I show the
demo and lastly like I mentioned with
standard tier you get three nines of
availability I want to note that the
availability SLA is applicable when we
go
ga-oh it's not applicable in the current
beta release okay so the other thing
that I want to touch upon is apart from
the tiers we also provide what we call
capacity tiers so the way we expose the
service is the more memory you provision
the more throughput you get so as you
can see in the table if you provision up
to thirty five gigabit gigabytes of
Redis you get about three gigabits per
second in terms of network throughput
and if you provision like greater than
100 gigabytes of right as you get 12
gigabits per second on network
throughput so the key thing to
note here is that when you plant your
Redis deployment using memory store you
want to consider what your application
throughput characteristics are and
depending on that size your reticent
since appropriately one of the Keith you
know aspects of bredis is that red is a
single-threaded so you always will have
in most cases you have sufficient CPU
for these instances the key thing that
you want to know is you know how much
network throughput you want to have
before you know the application
saturates a Redis server so the capacity
tier basically tells you the network
performance that you get it also
determines the pricing of the reticences
so the way we of priced memory store is
by gigabyte dollar per gigabyte hour so
what does that mean so for if you're
provisioning 1 to 4 gigabytes of Redis
so anywhere anything less than or equal
to 4 gigabytes you'll be charged at four
point nine cents per gigabyte are
similarly as you go higher up in the
capacity range obviously your gigabyte
our pricing is actually going to be
lower standard tier instance similarly
are priced using the same capacity range
arranges and but the pricing is going to
be more compared to the basic tier
instance like I said you know 12 memory
store is a mounted service so we make
this provisioning extremely simple we
allow you to provision memory stratus
using cloud console or command line or
using Google client libraries and the
other key thing that we have done is we
have integrated with terraform so if you
are managing your infrastructure as
infrastructure s code you can use
terraform to provision all the riders
instance one key thing i want to point
out is that we are supporting Redis
version 3.2.40 more versions later but
currently in beta what is available is
3.2.2 level just want to quickly touch
upon high availability and what we do
there are so the key
want to point out here about hi
available at the architecture or when
you deploy a standard tier instance is
that you're connecting to a single IP
and that basically your we take care of
the redirection of the application
connections to the right VMs if a beta
were happens the other thing is that we
you know we provide automatic failover
so we have our own health monitor that
monitors the instance we monitor the
health of the processes and if anything
goes wrong we automatically fail over
and the failover time is actually very
very fast it's actually in the order of
seconds so in terms of application
availability you get pretty good time
high availability with the standard tier
instance
and finally security the key thing that
we try to do with flawed memory store is
to protect the instance from external
attacks so wouldn't be provisioned the
instance we provision it using private
IP so when when you provision a cloud
memory store instance it's not action
accessible from the internet but and
because it is provisioned using a
private IP address the other thing he
thing you can do is to limit the access
of the instance using Virtual Private
Network and we also support cloud
identity and management roles so you
have granular I am roles it allows you
to control access to the Redis instance
based on your organizational rules and
the other key thing that I want to point
out which actually became relevant very
recently is critical patch management so
Redis recently announced a critical
patch we actually applied the patch even
before it was publicly announced so one
thing you can be sure off is that you're
reticent senses or cloud memory store
instances are always secure because we
take care of the patching and you don't
have to worry about it and finally I
want to touch upon some of the other
features and capabilities I talked about
scaling seamlessly so I'll really allow
scaling of the memory store instances
both basic and sanity r you can scale
your memory up and down with basic tier
obviously you will have your cache
flashbiz because it's a single instance
but the standard tiers scaling is a
highly available operation
we have integration with the stackdriver
and I'll talk more about it in the demo
and we also will be providing the
capability to back up your data using
our DB snapshots which will be coming
soon with the our DB snapshots is
currently or it's not currently
available in beta today but we plan to
make it available pretty soon and lastly
because we are built on open source
Redis we are protocol compatible so what
that means is that if you're running
your own radisson since today you can
switch over to memory store instance
with very little or actually no code
change and everything should just work
okay so that's kind of the summary of
the capabilities that we provide with
cloud memory stores so let me quickly
switch over to the demo and show you how
easy it is to deploy and manage clout
memory store so to get started you go to
the Google Cloud console and memory
store is a center it says storage and
database service so if you click on
cloud memory store it'll take you to the
memory store landing page one of the key
things I want to point out here is that
if you're a provisioning memory store
for the first time we automatically
enable the API for you and once API is
enabled you can start provisioning the
instance in this particular case I have
provisioned instances already but let's
go ahead and create an instance and see
how easy it is to do this so when you
provision an instance or the first thing
that you want to do is give it an
instance name I'm just going to give it
let's say demo instance - as I mentioned
the rightest version that we provide is
3.2 so you don't have an option to
select a version in the beta release but
we will be providing support for more
versions later on and the next choice
that you want to make is whether it's a
basic or a standard to your instance
like I mentioned earlier basic tier is a
standalone instance and standard here is
a replicated instance in this particular
case I'm going to choose standard
because I want to deploy a highly
available instance and the next thing
you want to do is select the region
where you want to deploy the instance
so the key thing I want to point out
here is that if you choose zone as any
we automatically pick the zones for you
for both the master and the replica but
if you want to specify the zone where
the master is going to be deployed at
the time of creation then you can go and
select a specific zone where you want to
deploy the master instance but even if
you select the zone for the master view
they will automatically select a zone
for the replica which is different from
the zone that you selected in this
particular case I'm just going to leave
it at any and over here you this is
where you select the size of the
reticent sense as I mentioned if you
change the size of the instance you
basically get different network
throughput so you want to be able to
determine what is the network throughput
that you want to get out of your
reticence sins and size the instance
accordingly and lastly you want to pick
the network that this net reticent since
it's going to be authorized to connect
so what that means is that oh yeah VMs
and connected to the BBC network where
the radisson census provision can
actually access this particular Redis
instance so let's go ahead and create
the instance so it's as you can see it
is actually very simple to go and create
this instance create a reticence since
using memory store one quick thing I do
want to point out is that I talked about
scaling so I already provisioned a basic
instance here and it is currently one
gigabyte now I want to go ahead and
change that to let's say 10 gigabyte as
you can see it's super easy all I won't
have to do is go to edit instance and
change the size of the instance and then
click Save and we automatically do the
scaling for you as I mentioned earlier
when you scale a basic tier instance we
recreate the instance so it's a full
flush of the cash but we preserve the IP
address so that applications can retry
and connect back to the same IP address
ok so now I talked about bread is
getting provisioned on a private IP
address as you can see the product the
IP that we currently use for the demo
instances 10.0
0.4 so from a connectivity perspective
there are a few things to keep in mind
one is you can only connect to the Redis
memory so Redis instance from within the
same region where you have deployed the
instance so that means you can connect
your application has to be running in US
central one to be able to connect to
this particular Redis instance secondly
you cannot access the Redis instance
outside of the region obviously if you
so for example if you are connecting
from your laptop or trying to connect
from your laptop to the Radisson since
you may not be able to do that directly
ok so let's look at connecting to the
rightest instance like I said right is
this protocol compatible so I'm just
going to quit run a quick you know
standard Redis benchmark and see if that
works and as you can see you know we use
open source Redis or any of the tools
that you use with open source Redis
works great in this particular case I'm
just running a Redis benchmark that
basically doesn't get set push on a pop
as you can see we get pretty good
performance when you're using memory
store instance now the interesting
question is okay how do you monitor the
instance as I mentioned earlier we have
integrated with stackdriver monitoring
so to get to start over let me quickly
show you how to do that so if you want
to get to stackdriver
and see the raddest instance you
basically just have to go under
stackdriver and click on monitoring and
if you launch stackdriver monitoring you
can get to the Redis dashboard so when
you look at the dashboard as you can see
we expose a whole bunch of metrics that
makes it very very easy for you to
monitor your Redis instance so in this
particular case you can see the average
network throughput you can see the CPU
utilization you can also see oops you
can see the average commands per second
you can see the 95th percentile latency
so there's a lot of things that we
actually expose as part of stack drivers
so let's take a look at what all the
metrics are that we expose so to see the
metrics what you can do is go to
resources and go to metrics Explorer and
just type in ready start Google API
and you will see the list of all the
metrics that are currently published for
you to monitor the Redis instance okay
so as I showed you it's very easy to go
deploy a reticence since it's protocol
compatible so that means any of the
tools will work that you're currently
using so if you're currently using
our self deployed reticence and your
applications are using you know Redis
for whatever reason it's very very easy
to switch to a memory store instance and
finally I touched upon some of the
features around monitoring so if you
want to be able to manage the reticence
ins it's very very easy to manage it
because we automatically provide the
monitoring for you so that you don't
have to integrate with any third-party
tools to do the monitoring like I
mentioned we take care of the management
of the reticence ins so that you don't
have to worry about patch management etc
all you have to worry about is just
writing your application and using Redis
for what it is you know meant meant for
okay so that's pretty much the club
memory store product it's currently in
beta we are planning to go GA pretty
soon but if you are interested in
testing the product you can do that
using free credits that are available
with the Google cloud platform and if
you want to have want to have more
information about memory store you can
also go to google.com slash memory store
where we have the documentation and more
information about the service thank you
very much now we are going to take the
Q&A
you
okay so we're we got a few questions in
the audience I'm just going to quickly
address some of the questions that are
showing up here so the first question is
will you be providing support for Redis
4.0 yes like I mentioned currently in
beta
we are only supporting 3.2 but we plan
to provide support for Redis 4.0 pretty
soon
we don't have exact timeline but soon
after GA we expect to be able to provide
support for rightis 4.0 the other
question is I see there the current
limit is 300 GB my application requires
close to a terabyte of Redis data what
are my options that's a very good
question so like I mentioned the basic
and standard tier are essentially single
instance reddit so what that means is
that there's only one master and it does
not rep you know scale out Redis cluster
solution so in this particular case one
option is to basically deploy multiple
instances of Redis and do a client-side
sharding that's one way to do it the
other thing that we are working on is
obviously Redis cluster again this is in
our roadmap and we're actually working
towards providing a Redis cluster but
till then the limit is going to be 300
GB is persistent supported in the
current release very good question so
this is something that currently is not
supported so let me clarify what we mean
uh let me clarify persistence a little
bit so there is both there's our DB and
then there is a Oh F at least in 3.2 so
we we plan to provide our DB snapshots
very quickly where you can take Rd B's
backups to a GCS bucket AOF is something
that we are working on and we should
have that pretty soon but currently
neither basic or standard tier provides
you of persistent and finally when is
the product going GA we expect the
product to go GA by September of this
year so your reer actively working
towards that and we hope to have that
released in September so that's all the
questions that we cut that that I have
thank you very much thank you for
attending the webinar have a great day